هل يمكن لهذا الحزب او غيره من التنظيمات
والمجمعات والحركات النسويه ان تحد من
تاثير هذه الجماعات ولا كل الدعم الموجه
لهذه الجماعات سيعقد هذه المساله عليهم
القادمه فقط
الحكومه لضمان ان هذه علاقه المصالح
المشتركه الموجوده موجود فتره طويله بين
الحكومه وجماعات الدينيه سوف تتلاشى وتكسر
والا النظام الالماني سيعود مره اخرى
لانعاشه والعظام القانوني بشكل اساسي سيسي
يستخدم
سنوات القادمه
اي مشكله
تهديدا للديمقراطيه حيث ان العديد من هذه
الجماعات الدينيه لا تعترف
بالجانب العلماني لي النظام السياسي
التركي
بغض النظر عن خلفياتهم الدينيه هو بسابع
علاقاتهم الوطيده مع الحزب الحاكم لديهم
الحصانه فالعديد من هذه الجماعات الدينيه
مع مرور السنوات تحولت الى جماعات
كم اندر سترون
شديده حققتها هذه الطفله يمكن ان تزوجت
برجل عمره 29 عاما من دون اي عواقب فاعتقد
ان هذا مؤشر واضح وكبير على ذلك فهم غير
مضطرين ولكن في السياقه التركيه فهم
يمثلون تهديدا
لتاسيسي النظام الديمقراطي الليبرالي